you spearheaded the NT weaponization
letter
uh Boston Dynamics has can you
describe uh what that letter States and
the general topic of the use of robots
in war
we uh authored a letter and then got
several leading robotics companies
around the world including you know
unitary and China and
agility here in the United States and
animal and in Europe
and you know some others to co-sign a
letter that said we won't put weapons on
our robots
and part of the motivation there is you
know as these robots start to become
commercially available
you can see videos online of people
who've gotten a robot and strapped a gun
on it and shown that they can you know
operate the gun remotely while driving
the robot around
and so having a robot that has this
level of Mobility
and that can easily be configured in a
way that could harm somebody from a
remote operator is
justifiably a scary thing
and so we felt like it was important to
draw a bright line there and say we're
not going to allow this
for
um
you know reasons that we think
ultimately it's better for the whole
industry if if it grows in a way where
robots are ultimately going to help us
all and make our lives more fulfilled
and productive but by goodness you're
going to have to trust the technology to
let it in and if
and if you think the robot's going to
harm you that's gonna that's gonna hurt
impede the growth of that industry
so we thought it was important to to
draw a bright line
and uh and then publicize that and and
our plan is to you know begin to engage
with
lawmakers and Regulators let's figure
out what the rules are going to be
around the use of this technology
um and use our position as leaders in
this industry and Technology
to help force that issue
and so we are in fact I have a I have a
policy you know director at my company
whose job it is to engage with the
public to enjoy engage with interested
parties and including Regulators to sort
of begin these discussions
he has a really important topic and it's
an important topic for people that worry
about the impact of robots on our
society with autonomous weapon systems
so I'm glad you're sort of leading the
way in this